[Music]
we shall have a cup of tea
they met in 1953 two young refugees over
bickies and tea
we didn't even say a word maybe you're a
bit too shy
it was love a first cup with a wink and
a smile
fae and joe gok danced down the aisle
as chinese were forbid by land and house
they leased a barn on a farm in auckland
south
they look all right they're not quite
ready yet joe some of them's ready
they'd escaped from a war and now had a
scheme to plant food in this earth
yes the gox had big dreams it's like a
woman you see the bulge and then you
know it's reading
oh do you feel where the bulge is
kumara kumara let's plant that said faye
with the tractor she talks to
and still drive today
their first year of crop they grew 160
ton and the gox were the stars of the
kumara run
oh look what i found this would be the
biggest one of this year yet
look at that and the times were changing
joe took a stand buying hundreds of
acres of fertile land
good morning joe what are you doing joe
loved to invent
he spearheaded a plan to grow kumara
seedlings by heating the land
oh well carry on good work think some
more
but their kumara bounty grew too large
to store it was starting to spoil
joe invented some more i'm not a
scientist but an experimenter
by controlling the warmth in his kumara
filled sheds it stayed fresh all year
round
and the industry cheered but all was not
well in the northern fields
on the dark of the flats the fields fell
to yield the kumara growers were down on
their knees black rot
had set in a killer disease you do it
would love it
tight tight tight portions so joe bred a
tuber resistant to bugs which we gave to
the north
with love and big hugs they gave it for
free to this land they adore
their gift back to new zealand they
don't ask for more
when the gox were still young chinese
folk would just few
new zealand today is a way different
hill he laughs out loud
if only they knew these chinese here now
of what we went through
65 long years on seven days of the week
it's knockoff time dad they're still up
with the sun
on their 80-plus feet don't walk so fast
you know i can't walk very fast
and kumara still is the cream of their
crop i think we've got enough i think
our dogs will have some as well
boiled roasted or mashed this go well
with the chocolate
here we are and for saving the kumara
they're called to stand up and awarded
with splendor the
letters low cup and the queen's service
medal
the highest of praise that's for you
joke for their services then till the
end of their days
so thank you we say to faye and joe gok
for their love of the kumara our most
precious crop it's terrible what's
happening in syria
we feel sorry for those people we're
very fortunate here we're eating the
best of food
and we're in new zealand
[Music]
no
you